bonjour merci et de nous rejoindre sur
public sénat le sénat poursuit cet
après-midi l'examen du projet de loi
relatif à l'élection des sénateurs
la séance autour de ce texte avait
débuté la semaine dernière et elle s'est
achevée après le rejet par le sénat des
deux motions déposées autour de ce texte
par l'opposition les sénateurs vont donc
commencer cet après-midi et bien
l'examen des articles autour de ce
projet de loi sur l'élection des
sénateurs alors je vous rappelle dans
les grandes lignes et bien les deux
principales mesures de ce projet de loi
tout d'abord et bien augmenter le nombre
de sénateurs élus à la proportionnelle
un nombre qui passerait de 50 2%
actuellement à 73% mêmes mais est
mécaniquement il y aurait également plus
de femmes élues ici au sénat puisque à
la proportionnelle est bien est attaché
la parité deuxième mesure principale sur
ce texte
le poids des grandes communes seraient
plus important puisqu'il y aurait
maintenant un délégué supplémentaire par
tranche de 800 habitants et non plus de
mille dans les communes de plus de 30
milles avant habitants donc voilà pour
les deux principales mesures autour de
ce projet de loi
l'opposition a dénoncé la semaine
dernière un tripatouillage électoral
la gauche elle souligne plutôt sa
volonté de rééquilibrage quant au poids
des grandes communes dans le corps
électoral des sénateurs alors pour bien
comprendre un petit peu tous les enjeux
autour de ce projet de loi et bien je
vous laisse juge je voulais suivre la
séance tout de suite sur notre antenne
très bonne après midi à tous
monsieur béchu je vous en prie merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission moi je
défends l'amendement d'yves détraigne
enfin pardon c'est un propre jeu le jeu
souhaite utiliser ce créneau
d'explications de vote pour vous
indiquer les raisons pour lesquelles je
vais le voter
l'argument selon lequel au motif que
tous les délégués sénatoriaux ne serait
pas
le même jour il y aurait la possibilité
d'une manipulation du corps électoral
est quelque chose qui me choque et
d'entendre les uns et les autres dans
cet hémicycle expliquer qu'on aurait des
moyens de pression sur l'ensemble des
élus locaux dès lors que ça s'étalerait
sur trois quatre cinq six ou sept jours
et quelque chose avec lequel j'ai
beaucoup de mal sur le plan du principe
si vraiment certains le pensent
comment se fait-il que la loi ne fixe
pas non seulement un jour mais une heure
pour que tous les conseils municipaux de
tout le département se réunissent
exactement même moment de manière à ce
qu'on évite qu'ils puissent y avoir un
conseil qui soient réunis le matin et
qui permettent au fur et à mesure de la
journée
un certain nombre de choses qui
pourraient s'organiser je ne vois pas en
quoi dans une assemblée qui fait le pari
de l'intelligence des territoires qui
sur beaucoup de texte appelle à la
responsabilité des élus locaux plaident
pour qu'on renforce leur responsabilité
et leur pouvoir
on viendrait ici dire méfions nous si
par hasard la commune intel avait voté
lundi on pourrait le mardi ou le
mercredi faire en sorte d'obtenir que le
conseil municipal modifie la liste de
ceux qui vont être présentés aux
suffrages
écoutez moi ça me ça me semble
véritablement est une hérésie par
rapport à la mission de cette haute
assemblée et de manière très large par
rapport à la conception que nous avons
du rôle des élus locaux au quotidien
vouloir croire que la manipulation ne
commencerait dès lors que le premier
conseil municipal aurait commencé
c'est assez surprenant où on a un moyen
de pression et dans ce cas là que tout
se fasse le même jour où sur plusieurs
jours
ça ne change pas grand chose où nous
n'avons pas et je ne vois pas au nom de
quoi on permettrait pas un minimum de
souplesse pour que les uns et les autres
s'organisent et au moment le président
de la république ne demande un choc de
simplification dont on mesure qui n'est
pas forcément évident dans tous les
domaines laissez un peu de souplesse à
nos assemblées locales
sincèrement ça embête qui merci monsieur
béchu me sujet l'art
merci ce président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues je suis en total
désaccord avec ce que viennent dire
notre collègue biche
en effet ce n'est pas seulement un
problème de logique délai élective qui
est en cause c'est avoir une tradition
républicaine
aussi loin que remonte l'élection des
sénateurs avec le mode de systèmes qui
est le nôtre nous avons toujours utilisé
ce système
à la même heure et en même temps c'est
la même heure 7 10 heures du mat en
règle générale le dimanche un jeu
rappelle cela 6,6 pour la provocation
bah oui mais c'est elle
traditionnellement c'était le préfet qui
convoquait la la fois ça n'a peut-être
pas été fait dans la tradition
républicaine voulais que ce soit
toujours à la même heure le même jour
deuxième élément je ne pense pas qu'il
ait manipulation chez les électeurs
les jets les candidats mais la
méditerranée pulation à venir d'autre
part elle peut venir de la presse qui va
analyser à chaque fois le scrutin du
lundi et valira il va falloir surveiller
de près ce que tu as du mardi parce que
dans telle commune le maire va pas
passer et ainsi de suite
donc cela permet non pas les
manipulations au sein des conseils
municipaux mais à l'extérieur de ceux ci
et puis personnellement je trouve que
quand tout a lieu le même jour à la même
heure
il ya une solennité qui apparaît et
cette solennité elle est bonne
merci madame ghoul c'est le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
lorsqu'ils detraigne a proposé cet
amendement moi je les ai pas je n'ai pas
signé je trouve qu'elle quand même une
facilité une simplification à ce que les
élections soient faites en même temps la
manipulation je n'y crois pas beaucoup
parce que dans les communes rurales
il est assez rare que les gens se
déclarent ou qu'ils aient une opinion au
politique particulière donc la
manipulation j'y crois pas et je pense
aussi aux services préfectoraux qui ont
quand même beaucoup de difficultés dans
les départements à connecter les données
à dresser les listes qu'on a jamais à
temps pour nos campagnes électorales
donc je pense que le fait que cette
élection se déroule le même jour à la
même heure pour toutes les communes est
une très bonne chose et je ferai pas
l'amendement d'yves détraigne merci
monsieur corner et bien moi je trouve
que les arguments de christophe béchu
sont excellents et c'est vrai qu'il faut
quand même faire confiance nous devons
faire confiance aux élus locaux et je
crois que apporter une certaine
souplesse et bienvenue pour désigner je
le rappelle monsieur gélard désigner les
grands électeurs c'est pas la même heure
c'est le même jour mais c'est pas la
même heure on n'a pas de nom c'est pas
une obligation la même heure et donc je
trouve que c'est important de garder une
certaine souplesse
alors maintenant que ce soit 3 jours une
semaine j'en sais rien l'essentiel c'est
de d'avoir deux d'introniser une
certaine souplesse dans cette élection
des grands électeurs et de faire
confiance aux élus locaux
il se trouve que deux d'être très
dirigiste et imposer un conseil
municipal à tel jour je trouve que c'est
d'un autre âge merci monsieur savary oui
mais je crois que beaucoup d'arguments
contraire sont développés mais si c'est
un amendement a été proposé par par yves
detraigne sénateur du département de la
marne c'est parce qu'ils les expriment
une remontée du terrain
c'est véritablement discutant avec les
grands électeurs qu'il ya des
propositions qui viennent comme ça je
crois que c'est important
l'émanation des territoires c'est aussi
le reflet de la réflexion locale et
plusieurs fois on a fait campagne
commune
plusieurs fois nous at on dit ben écoute
et fait en sorte qu' on puisse
introduire un peu de souplesse quoi ça
tombait l'élection des grands sénateurs
à jour y avait ce jumelage on a été
obligé d'annuler et c'est franchement si
on veut faire une campagne pour
l'élection
non pas pour l'élection pour la
désignation des grands électeurs
on a des mois des années pour la faire
ces pots dernier moment qu'on s'y prend
pour la désignation des grands électeurs
dont qui aura aucune pression et les
pressions deux dernières sont toujours
des mauvaises pression c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'expression des
territoires c'est un peu plus de
souplesse et une semaine me paraît tout
à fait intéressant merci monsieur mason
moi je voudrais dire que l'argument de
la pression sur les conseils municipaux
enfin ne me paraît pas du tout crédible
par contre ce qui me paraît beaucoup
plus crédible c'est le fait que en tant
que candidat aux élections sénatoriales
nous avons tous été confrontés au
problème de l'accès aux listes des
élections sénatoriales et moi je pense
que les préfectures déjà avec une
élection le même jour ils ont déjà
beaucoup de mal de nous donner des
listes qui sont un jour parce que quinze
jours après on y va non il ya une erreur
il ya un tel on a mis un tel etc
bon si on étale sa sur huit jours ça va
être le foutoir complet et moi je pense
je pense qu'il ya quand même bon il faut
quand même temps il faut imaginer par
monroe département il ya sept cent
trente sept ans 50 communes bon c'est
quelque chose d'extravagant parce que
parfois bon bah on va aller les gens
répondent pas et c'est bon ben si le
préfet doit attendre huit jours de plus
pour constater que les gens n'ont pas
répondu et cetera
et bien c'est quelque chose qui va peau
qui va aggraver les problèmes de
faciliter d'accessibilité aux listes
électorales des électeurs définitive des
électeurs sénatoriaux donc moi je suis
le premier à reconnaître que l'argument
dépression bon c'est on est quand même
dans un monde où la démocratie
maintenant fait son trou en france et
vouloir faire croire qu'ils auraient à y
aura des pressions sur telle ou telle
commune
ça c'est ça me paraît pas très très je
ne dirais pas sérieux mais tout au moins
pas très convaincant par contre le la
il faut se mettre à la place des préfets
des préfectures des services des
élections dans les préfectures et je
pense qu'ensuite on serait mal venu si
on leur compliquer le travail on sera
mal venu pour venir se plaindre que le
travail est pas bien fait merci monsieur
cointin
une seule résidence ministre mes chers
collègues je ne pense pas qu'il y ait de
manipulation comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure du corps électoral
pendant une semaine où se déroulerait la
désignation des délégués
mais je voudrais rester dans le domaine
de la cohérence en effet qu'on le
veuille ou pas on est bien obligé de
constater que quand une ville d'eysines
ses délégués ça donne une indication sur
la température politique et qu'on ne
peut pas ne pas en tenir compte et elle
ville qui fera la désignation après une
autre pourrait être tenté de modifier
éventuellement son choix en fonction des
résultats des élections précédentes
qu'on le veuille ou pas c'est ainsi et
la preuve dans la cohérence c'est que
vous même vous avez reconnu
vous avez voté j'ai voté nous avons voté
que les élections dans certaines pays du
monde notamment polynésie et lieu le
samedi pour que justement les électeurs
quand il vote ne soient pas influencés
par les résultats donnés par les
journalistes sur l'état des élections or
qu'est ce que nous faisons ici je vais
le dire mon ami yves detraigne nous
sommes en train de le dire mais on va
faisait les chaussures une semaine comme
ça vous pourrez voir un peu ce qui se
passe ailleurs
non je crois que dans la république il
faut être cohérent est de cohérence de
faire le même jour à la même heure
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix le
sous-amendement 62 madame lipietz qui a
reçu l'avis défavorable de la commission
et du gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté je
mets donc aux voix l'amendement 11
rectifié terre qui a reçu l'avis
défavorable et de la commission et du
gouvernement l'amendement monsieur
detraigne quels sont ceux qui sont pour
son adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté
nous en arrivons à 3 amendement faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 32 monsieur gorce
est ce qu'il tombe celui-ci alors il est
défendu
enfin il n'est pas défendu ils tombent
amendement 58 de monsieur favier oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
d'abord peut-être un petit rappel
nécessaire pour comprendre la nature et
le sens de cet amendement le projet de
loi qui avait été présenté par le
gouvernement de lionel jospin en 1999
proposait une disposition similaire donc
à savoir de désigner un grands électeurs
d'élire un grand électeur pour 500
habitants mais au cours de la navette à
l'initiative d'autres groupes d'ailleurs
reprise par la majorité de l'assemblée
nationale à l'époque le parlement a
décidé d'établir le seuil de désignation
de grands électeurs à 1 pour 3 100
quelle que soit la taille de la ville
et c'est sur cette base là le conseil
constitutionnel par une décision du 6
juillet 2000 a censuré cet article en
indiquant que la proposition dépassait
le principe de correction démographique
acceptées jusqu alors les délégués
supplémentaires devenait majoritaire
dans le collège électoral donc au
détriment des membres des conseils
municipaux
le conseil constitutionnel d'ailleurs
c'est puis effectivement faisant
référence à certains départements nous
estimons qu'avec notre proposition donc
d'un grand électeur pour 500 habitants
le constat du conseil constitutionnel ne
sera plus le même s'il est saisi et que
nous revenons donc dans le schéma d'une
correction démographique en tout cas
contrairement à ce qui n'a pas été
indiqué en commission cet amendement
n'est pas contraire à la décision le
conseil constitutionnel puisque il est
sensiblement différent de la disposition
censurée
la décision du conseil constitutionnel
ne portait pas sur le principe de
l'élargissement donc du corps électoral
où le mécanisme de désignation du
nouveau collège électoral mais sur les
conséquences chiffrées
nous demandons donc d'examiner
précisément cette proposition qui vise
on le voit donc à renforcer la
légitimité du cema et à rééquilibrer la
représente
s'ils ont des zones urbaines et des
zones rurales merci amendement 31
rectifié de madame claisse
oui merci monsieur le président je pense
qu'il n'a échappé à personne vu la
ferveur des débats jusqu'à présent que
la constitution du collège des grands
électeurs présente un certain nombre de
petites erreurs ou d'anomalies non je
n'ai certainement pas la prétention en
un seul amendement de les résoudre tous
néanmoins il ya quand même une anomalie
qui saute aux yeux quand on regarde le
tableau de la répartition de ces grands
électeurs c'est l'apparition d'une
tranche cool de strate de population
pour les communes qui concerne vous me
pardonnerez je vais passer sur les 999
pour aller plus vite dans mon propos
mais une tranche de population neuf à
dix mille habitants
c'est uniquement pour le code électoral
et depuis 56 58 je ne sais plus qui est
apparue cette tranche dans le code
électoral
nul n'en connaît plus aujourd'hui les
raisons et elle ne correspond en tout
cas à rien dans le code général des
collectivités territoriales et notamment
elle ne correspond pas non plus à une
composition différente du conseil
municipal donc ma proposition et de
rectifier ce que j'appelle une
incohérence et de fusionner ces deux
tranches 5 à 9 mille habitants et neuf à
dix mille habitants pour n'en faire
qu'une seule qui serait représenté au
niveau du collège des grands électeurs
par 27 grands électeurs ça diminue un
tout petit peu la représentativité pour
les communes de neuf à dix mille salles
augmente de façon de semble-t-il
significative logique et cohérente pour
les communes 2,5 à 9000
ça fait donc une seule tranche qui sera
représentée par vinci park 27 oui
conseillers municipaux et au delà de dix
mille ce serait tout conseil municipal
donc la logique voulue par le
législateur dans le code électoral en
construisant ce tableau des grands
électeurs ne sera en rien perturbé et on
récupère elle a une anomalie me
semble-t-il
merci madame avis de la commission sur
ces deux amendements monsieur le
rapporteur sur le premier amendement de
monsieur favier l'avis de la commission
était demande de retrait ou avis
défavorable puisqu'il a été référence il
a été fait référence à la décision du
conseil communal du 6 juillet 2000 qui
précise que la part des grands électeurs
non élu au suffrage universel direct ne
doit pas être sûr
en ciel au niveau national et ne doit
pas être majoritaire dans un département
à l'exception du cas de paris et que
c'est vrai qu'en élisant un nombre
important de grands électeurs dont les
départements comme les bouches du rhône
ont dépassé largement la moitié de
grands électeurs qui n'aurait pas été
élu au suffrage universel direct mais
élu ensuite par les différents conseils
municipaux et donc pour ces raisons
liées à la décision du conseil
constitionnel l'avis de la commission
est défavorable ensuite sur l'amendement
de madame claisse la commission avait
demandé une rectification de la part de
l'auteur pour tenir compte d'une
progressivité puisqu'au début dans
l'amendement initial
madame claisse souhaité maintenir 15
délégués pour la tranche de trois mille
cinq à 5000 habitants
à voir en fait 25 délégués de 100 milles
à 9000 et gardez donc les 29 de 9 mais
l'asie 1000 dons qu'elle rectifie son
amendement pour faire une seule tranche
de 5000 à 10000 ce n'était pas vraiment
l'esprit de la commission qui souhaitait
plutôt conserver les 29 délégué de 9000
à 10000 mais peut-être établir un nombre
de délégués intermédiaire pour la
tranche de 5000 à 9000 en augmentant le
nombre actuel de 15
peut-être à 21 dont la mesure où le
sous-amendement de classe ne va pas dans
le sens des demandes de la commission
je ne peux pas lui donner un avis
favorable merci monsieur rapporte à vis
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président très rapidement
sur l'amendement de monsieur favier le
gouvernement y est défavorable puisque
celle équilibres du texte qui s'en
trouveraient touché parce que votre
amendement monsieur le sénateur a comme
pour conséquence de fortement réduire la
représentation des plus petites communes
dans les communes de 500 habitants le
nombre de délégués par commune serait
divisé par trois d'où l'opposition du
le gouvernement à cet amendement quand
un amendement de madame plesse en vous
demandant si vous le souhaiter de bien
vouloir le retirer le gouvernement
souhaite éviter la multiplication des
str ap source de nouveaux effets de
seuil et compliquant ainsi très
honnêtement la tâche en termes de
représentation et l' équilibre actuel
merci explications de notre monsieur
richard mais monsieur le président je me
permettrait de présenter une suggestion
à nos collègues de l'amendement de
madame laisse je crois évoque un sujet
tout de même assez sérieux sur la
composition du collège sénatoriales en
effet le collège sénatorial doit être
composé de représentants des
collectivités et conseil constitutionnel
nous a rappelé que cette représentation
des collectivités devaient représente
devaient respecter leur diversité donc
qu'il ne devait pas aller jusqu'à une
proportionnalité démographique complète
en revanche le conseil nous dit les
délégués supplémentaires ou la
progression du nombre de délégués en
fonction de la population a pour objet
d'opérer un correctif démographique et
ceci est conforme à la constitution
or il saute aux yeux quand on regarde le
tableau que ce correctif démographique à
des problèmes de cohérence jusqu'à 3500
habitants
vous avez une représentation des
communes dans le collège qui au fond est
plafonné à un délégué pour 500 habitants
entre 500 et 1500 vous avez trois
délégués entre 500 entre 1500 et 2500 av
donc à chaque fois vous partez pour
redescendre et à chaque tranche d'un
nombre d'électeurs plus bas est remonté
jusqu'à saint xandre or à 3500 vous
passez d'un seul coup de 7 à 15
donc vous avez une représentation plus
favorable et commune de 3500 habitants
que des communes de 2500 habitants
première incohérence deuxième
incohérences avait le même nombre de
délégués de 3500 habitants à lui 1999
vous avez un écart de plus de 2 dans
cette même tranche suite nouvelle nouvel
effet de seuil que rappeler le virginie
qui est que à 9000 un habitant vous
passer de 15 à 29 délégué donc vous
retombez un niveau de représentation du
délégué supplémentaire qui est plus bas
que celui de la commune de 3000
habitants
donc nous devrions me semble-t-il
profité du fait que nous aurons de
lecture pour réexaminer ces quelques
points de différence de représentation
mais donc je veux me permet de me
différencier du ministre en disant que
si on veut que le correctif
démographique qui doit accompagner la
représentation et compléter la
représentation des collectivités si on
veut que ce correctif démographique ne
comportent pas d'anomalies de
représentation il faudrait le travailler
avec un nombre de strates légèrement
augmenté dans cette tranche entre 3500
et 10 mai il n'est pas raisonnable de
chercher improvisé maintenant parce que
nous avons abordé ce problème
trop tard et d'ailleurs on doit
remercier virginie klès de la barre
soulevée mais il me semble que nous nous
finirions pas le travail de
d'amélioration et d'équilibrage du
collège sénatoriales si nous ne
saisissions pas la seconde lecture pour
travailler plus en détail sur ce sujet
merci monsieur richard monsieur tu rêves
à ce président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues juste un petit propos
pour venir en soutien à l'amendement de
ma collègue si sa dernière
vous tire pas pour bien bien exprimer le
fait que si j'ai bien compris en fait
elle ne multiplie pas les strates
en fait elle en supprime une dans son
amendement et c'est justement la portion
de communes qui se situe entre 5000 et
9000 habitants permettez moi qui se
trouve aujourd'hui sous représentés
c'est effectivement le cas notamment
pour la circonscription que je
représente à autre à l'assemblée à la
haute assemblée
je crois que c'est un peu aussi le cas
pour la plupart des communes de
calédonie nouvelle calédonie c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'avoue avoir une
analyse assez favorable de cet
amendement là je veux tourner à
l'expliquer et éventuellement a aussi
apporté ma voix dans le cas où cette
dernière soutient et défend sur d'un
mouvement
merci beaucoup madame claisse oui merci
monsieur président et voilà bien
dubitatif parce que effectivement
monsieur ministre je supprimer une
strate mais en entendant mon collègue
richard je me dis qu'il fallait peut
être en démultiplier j'ai envie quand
même de maintenir l'amendement
au moins pour que l'on se saisisse
effectivement du sujet parce que si
imparfait il est et qu'il devait être
votée ça nous obligera à leur travail
est effectivement en deuxième lecture
et puis si jamais par hasard il était
parfait beau temps le voter maintenant
je crois pas beaucoup à la deuxième
solution est donc je maintiens mon
amendement pour comment se saisisse du
sujet et qu'on leur travail
effectivement sans doute plus à fond en
deuxième lecture
merci monsieur de ligier j'ai écouté
avec beaucoup d'attention les
explications de notre collègue richard
qui me paraît intéressante sur le plan
intellectuel et qui méritent d'être
approfondis alors je sais pas ça colle
tout à fait avec l'amendement de madame
haute lesse
mais c'est intéressant parce que ça
aurait au moins l'avantagé de redonner
un peu j'irai de vigueur à ce qu'on peut
appeler le monde rural enfin les
communes de taille moyenne ou petite
j'ai alors bien sûr que ça ne plaise pas
à dire au ministre de l'intérieur au
gouvernement je le comprends puisque ça
va un peu à l'encontre le ski est
souhaitée dans ce texte c'est de
redonner un peu plus de poids aux
grandes communes on l'a tous bien
compris enfin moi j'appelle ça les
textes rural ici d'un dont l'objectif
les uns après les autres que ce soit
celui là où que ce soit celui qui
concerne l'élection des conseillers
généraux et cetera bon l'objectif c'est
quand même un petit peu d'affaiblir le
monde rural et je trouve que c'est
intéressant de regarder la réflexion de
monsieur richard n'ont pas de voter
l'amendement parce qu'ils méritent un
approfondissement
mais le regarder si au travers de cette
intervention on peut pas redonner un peu
plus de poids au monde rural plutôt que
de redonner toujours un peu plus de
poids à la métropolisation grandes
communes etc
le sénat s'est quand même l'aménagement
du territoire et c'est pas uniquement la
représentation des grandes communes
merci monsieur le ministre je président
la réflexion et bien sûr intéressante je
n'en doute pas
d'ailleurs je ne suis pas sûr monsieur
le sénateur que la proposition de madame
claisse ne poserait pas de problème de
représentation au monde rural donc
moi je vous propose madame claire
vraiment c'est de prendre en
considération la proposition d'alain
richard pour que nous puissions
l'étudier gouvernement donne non pas un
avis défavorable mais vous a demandé de
le retirer pour qu'on puisse étudier de
près si le sénat mais à condition de
trouver les voies de consensus sur ce
sujet gouvernement est prêt à étudier
avec vous ces éléments de seuil à la
fois sans complexifier le problème en
prenant le temps même temps il faudra
aller vite
il y aura aussi évidemment une lecture à
l'assemblée nationale avant la deuxième
lecture qui évoquait le sénateur alain
richard mais regardons de près toutes
les conséquences d'un tel élément
pas sûr que votre amendement sera par
ailleurs adopté par le sénat sans
préjuger du vote de chacun d'entre vous
mais moi je préfère que vous retiriez le
problème a été soulevé et étudions le
ensemble pour voir si des choses peuvent
être améliorées sans rompre les
équilibres auxquels vous êtes tous
je me permets de rappeler attaché merci
monsieur le ministre madame claisse
devant les assurances promise par le
ministre dans l'hémicycle j'accepte de
retirer l'amendement
et je suis tout à fait prêt à travailler
avec qui voudra sur le sujet merci
l'amendement donc ce 31 rectifié retirer
et je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement 58 de monsieur favier qui a
reçu l'avis défavorable de la commission
chauffe s'il est retirée il a maintenu
que monsieur favier il a maintenu et
l'avis défavorable du gouvernement quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté nous
en arrivons avant l'article 1er à un
amendement 42 rectifié terre de monsieur
corps nus ou monsieur montgolfier
présent mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre c'est un amendement
de conséquences nous avons tout à
l'heure et reproduit dans le corps
électorale des sénateurs les sénateurs
eux mêmes et donc en conséquence il vous
est proposé de modifier l'article l 287
du code électoral pour inclure le mot
sénateurs les sénateurs et un sénateur
sais pas si c était satisfait par le
sous amendement du gouvernement tout à
l'heure mais un tel cas il y aurait lieu
de tirer les conséquences de notre vote
de tout à l'heure merci quel est l'avis
de la commission sur cet amendement de
conséquences je vais très laconique la
vie est bien évidemment favorables à il
s'agit de tirer les conséquences du vote
qui est déjà intervenu donc l'avis de la
commission est favorable
merci même avis du gouvernement merci
donc je mets aux voix cet amendement de
monsieur cornu qui a reçu l'avis
favorable de la commission et la sagesse
du gouvernement quels sont ceux qui sont
pour son adoption
avis contraire unanimité il est adopté
nous en arrivons à l'article 1er j'ai
une demande de prise de parole de
monsieur jean louis masson donner la
parole monsieur masson monsieur le
président chers collègues je l'avais dit
dans le débat général
autant je suis plutôt favorable à
l'article 2 autant je suis très hostile
à l'opération qui consiste à augmenter
encore le poids des grandes villes parce
qu'à force d'augmenter le poids des mots
de grandes villes finalement on arrive à
déstabiliser la finalité profonde du
sénat qui est de représenter les
territoires avec les redécoupage des
cantons qui ont été qui sont programmés
qui vont avoir lieu et je comprends
qu'il faille redécouper les cantons
parce que les écarts de population était
trop important mais avec les redécoupage
des cantons on va déjà je dirai donnez
jorat un poids beaucoup plus fort aux
villes qu au départ coco campagne dans
dans la gestion des départements
je pense qu'il est important que le
sénat reste le défenseur des territoires
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense qu'il n'est pas très opportun de
vouloir revenir sur le
sur le taux de représentativité de un
pour mille de le faire passer un pour
mission merci monsieur masson nous en
arrivons à 4 amendement faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune quatre
amendements de suppression à commencer
par le numéro deux du président gaudin
qu'il défend monsieur de montgolfier
merci monsieur mais dans le cynisme et
chers collègues alors nous arrivons là
en effet l'essentiel après avoir discuté
beaucoup de procédures de demande de
grâce au lecteur hall nous n'arrivons à
la définition du coeur électorale qu'on
nous propose de modifier puisque
l'article premier du texte modifierait
l'article l 285 du code électoral en
diminuant le nombre de délégués qui
passerait donc de 1800 habitants dans
les communes depuis trois mille
habitants est ce qu aboutir à la
désignation de délégués supplémentaires
alors bien sûr la motivation de cette de
cette modification avait clairement
indiqué dans le rapport j'ai lu avec
attention le rapport et le rapportait on
nous dit ça pour objet d'assurer une
meilleure représentation de la
population des villes des communes les
peuples paix et des zones urbaines
je regrette jacques terral donc ça
dépend des finitions si on va sur et
meilleure augmentation des zones
urbaines veut dire qu'on souhaite
assurer une mois de représentations des
zones rurales et c'est la raison pour
laquelle évidemment nous proposons la
suppression de cet article premier qui
ne se justifie pas il faut en effet
tenir compte également du contexte on a
parlé un instant des cantons diminution
par deux du nombre de cantons
c'est un des très grands territoires
avec l'augmentation du nombre des élus
je vois pas très bien l'intérêt s'est
constitué une mesure en effet qui contre
le monde rural ça c'est la raison de fou
mais il ya également une raison de forme
et de calendrier nous sommes le 18 juin
les élections en 18 juin 2013
les élections auront lieu sénatoriales
ont lieu en septembre 2014 et la
tradition républicaine nous savons c'est
de ne pas modifier l'élection le mode
d'élection le corps électoral dans
l'année qui précède l'élection
allons nous sommes déjà en juin on nous
annonçait deux lectures sur ce texte des
lectures sur ce texte
c'est à dire concrètement il faudra
l'assemblée nationale on a certes une
session extraordinaire
nous avons tous reçu le décret du 14
juin 2013 qui convoque le parlement en
session extraordinaire pour le lundi 1er
juillet 2013
mais quand je vois qu'à 4
page d'ordre du jour dans ce décret j'ai
quelques doutes puisque on va commencer
par le conseil supérieur de magistrature
l'interdiction du cumul la transparence
vie politique
le procureur de la république financier
l'audiovisuel public la brassant des
comptes
la pupille de l'état l'état l'outre-mer
et caetera et caetera et caetera et les
sénateurs j'ai quelques doutes que dans
cette session extraordinaire extrêmement
chargé qui comporte également à débat
d'orientation des finances publiques un
débat sur la politique agricole commune
nous soyons en mesure de modifier le le
corps électoral en respectant cette
tradition qui consiste à ne pas agir
dans l'année qui précède l'élection
sénatoriale donc concrètement compte
tenu du fait qu'il ya deux lectures sur
ce texte il serait beaucoup plus sage de
supprimer l'article 1er est de laisser
le corps électoral en l'état c'est à
dire contre ne pas vouloir à quelques
semaines mais de quelques mois des
élections vouloir que tripatouiller le
correcteur hall en réduisant 2000 à 800
le nombre d'habitants qui se justifie
pas sur le fond mais sur la forme je
crois que c'est une atteinte au principe
qui consiste cette tradition largement
établie qui consiste à ne pas toucher au
rectorat dans l'année qui précède
l'élection en par une fois la session
extraordinaire est insuffisamment chargé
je ne vois pas comment nous pourrions
avoir achevé ce texte avant le mois de
septembre
voilà les raisons pour laquelle au nom
de notre groupe on nous proposons de
supprimer l'article premier du texte du
présent texte
merci monsieur de montgolfier amendement
23 monsieur masson monsieur bré en vga
expliquer mon point de vue je pense que
non pas pour des raisons de de stabilité
du système électoral à un an de
l'échéance pas ce que c'est c'est une
règle qui est très facile c'est même pas
vrai et c'est une habitude très récente
et qui qui n'a pas de fondement
juridique mais simplement pour défendre
les zones rurales pour leur préserver
une certaine représentation et notamment
défendre les communes rurales moi je
propose la suppression idéalement donc 2
cet article il ya maintenant trente de
monsieur collombat bien comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'expliquer lors du vote
sur la motion donc la question préalable
autant je pense que la disposition du
projet de loi étendant le champ de mode
de scrutin proportionnel ne changera pas
beaucoup en tout cas on sait pas ce que
ça peut donner au niveau de l'expression
des territoires ruraux
autant il est bien évident que cette
disposition vise à amoindrir la capacité
d'expression donc de ses terres de ses
territoires ruraux même si je reconnais
bien volontiers que in fine et la portée
pratique de la disposition est tout à
fait limité
pour moi c'est une question de principe
merci amendement 39 ce monsieur
detraigne oui monsieur le président ça
va pas vous surprendre si je vous dis
comme je l'avais indiqué au cours de la
discussion générale que nous sommes
résolument opposés à la cette
disposition
l'abaissement de 1000 1 800 du nombre
d'habitants ouvrant droit à un délégué
supplémentaire de les communes de plus
de 30000 habitants
pourquoi d'abord parce que c'est
clairement une atteinte portée au monde
rural qui vient déjà d'être fortement
atteint contre l'avis du sénat avec la
création pour les élections
départementales du fameux pilum binôme
paritaire
deuxièmement l'étude d'impact est très
incomplète par rapport à la disposition
qui nous est proposé on nous indique que
cela devrait avoir un effet sur 3000
délégués supplémentaires mais nous
n'avons aucune indication département
par département or c'est bien à
l'échelle des départements que les et
que les élections sénatoriales
sénatoriales ont lieu
et enfin on arriverait à une
augmentation du nombre de délégués
supplémentaires dans un certain nombre
de départements tels que l'on pourrait
dire qu'un certain nombre de sénateurs
devraient alors et lacs leur élection
totalement à ses délégués
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas eux
mêmes des élus de terrain des élus
locaux donc je pose que je pense que ça
pose un vrai problème par rapport aux
rôles même pas du sénateur qui est le
représentant le sénat étant le
constitutionnellement leurs
représentants des collectivités
territoriales de la république donc pour
cette raison nous sommes totalement
opposés à cet article merci monsieur
detraigne avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur sur ces quatre amendements
identiques
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
à ces quatre amendements
il ya deux dispositions dans ce texte de
loi la proportionnelle pour les
appartements qui vont élire trois
sénateurs et un nombre de grands
électeurs dans les communes de plus de
30000 habitants qui va un tout petit peu
augmenté
cela a été dit il y aura trois mille
grands électeurs supplémentaires sur un
total de 151 1000 il s'agit donc de
corriger de rectifier d'équilibré pour
faire en sorte que les villes
importantes soit un petit peu mieux
représentées qu'aujourd'hui mais quoi
qu'il en soit et je veux rassurer tous
ceux qui s'érigent en défenseurs du
monde rural le monde rural reste très
très largement avantagés puisque dans
les petites communes un grand électeur
va continuer à représenter 200 300
habitants alors que dans les grandes
villes dont la population est supérieure
à 30 mille aujourd'hui un grand électeur
représente 1000 habitants demain avec la
modification un grand électeur
représentera 750 habitants donc on voit
qu'on va corriger mais que le monde
rural va rester privilégiées dans la
désignation du nombre de grands
électeurs ramené à la population
j'ajoute que s'il a été fait référence à
un usage d'une pas modifier les règles
électorales
à un an des élections ce n'est qu'un
usage et je précise aussi que nous
sommes encore loin des élections
sénatoriales qui vont se dérouler en
septembre n'ont pas 2013 dans trois mois
mais 2014
donc nous sommes quand même à quinze
mois de la prochaine élection
sénatoriale dans la moitié des
appartements
je crois que ça laisse largement le
temps au parlement de voter la loi et je
suis certain que rapidement tous les
candidats seront bien informée de cette
petite modification du corps électoral
pour les élections de septembre 2014
ensuite il a été fait référence
également la décision du conseil
national qui c'est vrai précise bien
qu'il ne faut pas que dans un
département à l'exception de la capitale
il y est plus de grands électeurs nos
élus que de grands électeurs élus et
dans l'étude d'impact
on voit bien que le département qui est
le plus concerné par la modification
proposée il s'agit des bouches du rhône
vers et la part de grands électeurs non
élus passé sur l'ensemble du corps
électoral de 32% à 36 % et sans être un
grand mathématicien je crois que vous
aurez compris que de 36 à 50
il y a encore beaucoup de marge de
manoeuvre d'ailleurs cette modification
qui vise à rééquilibrer et à mettre un
peu de justice dans la représentation
des territoires a été jugée souvent
modestes par de nombreux groupes
politiques
mais je crois qu'il faut aller dans ce
sens qu'il faut rééquilibrer de manière
raisonnable en faisant passer la tranche
de 1 grands électeurs pour 1000
habitants à 1 pour 8 cents on tient
compte des évolutions démographiques
on montre aussi que les grandes villes
doivent être prises en considération
sans pour autant les opposer au monde
rural qui continuent à être privilégiée
dans la répartition des grands électeurs
il s'agit comme cela a été dit dans le
bain général d'une modification qui je
crois est raisonnable et va dans le sens
d'une plus grande légitimité pour le
sénat qui a bien sûr vocation à
représenter le monde rural mais
également les villes et les grandes
villes il ne faut pas opposer l'un à
l'autre les deux sont complètement
complémentaires le monde urbain a besoin
du monde rural et le monde rural a
besoin du monde urbain est ici le sénat
a vocation à représenter toutes les
collectivités qu'elles soient rurales ou
urbaines
merci monsieur rapporteur monsieur le
président de la commission monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je suis quelque peu étonné par
certaines réactions aux interventions
l'objet de cette proposition de loi de
ce projet de loi sera pour les villes de
30000 à 40000 habitants
de faire passer le nombre d'habitants
ont représenté par un grand électeur de
800 à 780 il y a en réalité d'immenses
disparités immense puisque vous savez
bien qu'il y a des cas où un grand
électeur représente 800 habitants et des
cas où il représente 100 habitants voire
50 habitants voire dix habitants donc le
gouvernement en présentant ce projet de
loi a fait preuve d'une modération que
je tiens à saluer d'une modération que
je tiens à saluer dans le respect des
communes rurales parce que si on avait
choisi de prendre davantage en compte
tout simplement la démographie est après
tout le principe d'égalité
on aurait pu et préconisé des
changements du type de ceux qui a
préconisé madame classe ou des
changements plus ample encore alors le
gouvernement ne le fait pas la majorité
ne le fait pas alors merci de ne pas
instruire un procès qui en l'espèce n'a
pas lieu d'être
merci monsieur le président à vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre oui
c'est difficile d'argumenter davantage
après les propos du rapporteur et du
président mais là bon cet article vous
le savez pour objectif de rééquilibrer
la représentativité entre les
différentes catégories de communes afin
de tenir compte de la croissance
démographique et en même temps l'article
24 de la constitution ne nous oblige pas
à une stricte égalité de la
représentation et en même temps nous
avons la décision du conseil
constitutionnel de 2000 donc avec ces
éléments là et en étant particulièrement
prudents nous opérons un changement un
réquilibrage mais qui ne remet pas en
cause les grands équilibres et qui reste
très favorable au monde rural
pour ce qui concerne la désignation des
délégués sénatoriaux donc avec cette
prudence
l'application de l'article 24 de la
constitution les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel
et cette évolution pense que nous
permettront d'évoluer favorablement mais
de rester dans un équilibre qui je crois
honnêtement devrait convenir à tous et
qui ne représente en rien un
bouleversement et qui ne méritent aucune
critique sévère sur ce sujet merci
monsieur le ministre
donc défavorable défavorable chers
collègues je suis heureux de saluer la
présence dans la tribune officielle de
madame mia petra kung fu l'anah tri
présidente de la grande commission de
l'es12 kounta ferland finlandaise
madame comme fullana tri est en visite
en france pour une série d'entretiens
sur les questions européennes
elle s'est entretenue au sénat avec
notre collègue simon sutour président de
la commission des affaires européennes
en notre nom à tous je lui souhaite la
plus cordiale bienvenue et bon séjour en
france
monsieur châtillon pour explication de
vote
monsieur le président simplement pour
répondre à monsieur le ministre
dès l'instant où on veut effectivement
augmenter la représentation des grandes
communes en évoqué tout à l'heure
l'opération qui consisterait à remettre
également à niveau pour le rural pour
les communes de 5000 à 10000 habitants
est-ce que sur cet amendement il faut
pas là aussi se dire que l'on met toutes
ensemble ont fait l'étude est une tâche
de représenter le plus tôt possible mais
on le fait à la fois pour le rural est à
la fois pour l'urbain mais je ne vois
pas pourquoi on traiterait immédiatement
une meilleure représentation d'urbain au
détriment de rural sans évoquer le
problème du rural
merci monsieur chatouille monsieur de
lège
merci président ministres effectivement
qu'on parle d'élection et de
représentation faut trouver le juste
équilibre entre une représentation de la
population c'est-à-dire une
représentation démographique mais aussi
une représentation des territoires
force est de constater que tous les
textes que vous nous soumettez depuis
quelques semaines vont tous dans le même
sens ils vont tous dans le même sens et
le message est très clair fait une
atténuation de la représentation
territoriale au profit d'une
représentation démographique et par
conséquent vous pouvez pas nous dire
monsieur le ministre la main sur le
coeur votre attachement aux territoires
ruraux et en même temps à chaque texte
on voyait toujours le même message et
que vous le vouliez ou non je les
regardais dans mon secteur mais chacun a
pu le faire dans son département
c'est pas tant la division par deux du
nombre de cantons
qui me préoccupe mais le fait que vous
avez veillé à faire en sorte que le
redécoupage des cantons se fasse
essentiellement et c'est bien le terme
dans la loi essentiellement sur une base
territoriale
ce qui aura pour effet dans chaque
conseil général d'amoindrir la
représentation territoriale au profit
d'une représentation démographique car
c'est bien dans la loi le terme
essentiellement sur une base
démographique que vous avez fait voter à
l'assemblée
contrairement à ce que nous souhaitions
ici au sénat c'est à dire une
possibilité de s'écarter de la moyenne
démographique de plus ou de moins 30% et
là avec la délai la désignation des
grands électeurs une fois de plus on va
dans le sens du d'un amoindrissement de
la représentation territoriale et par
conséquent je ne voterai pas comme
beaucoup de mes collègues cet article je
veux très l'amendement qui vise à le
supprimer
parce que encore une fois ce sont les
territoires ruraux qui vont faire les
frais de cette réforme et je ne sais pas
si vous aviez des intentions malignes
par rapport un résultat électoral que
vous anticipez riez je ne peux pas le
croire et par conséquent j'en conclus
que la seule justification c'est
l'affaiblissement des territoires ruraux
merci monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président de me laisser
répondre dans un un dialogue parce que
moi je le veux pas de malentendu et et
encore moins de faux procès et en
l'occurrence c'est un faux procès que
vous confondez deux choses l'élection
des délégués au sénat et l'élection
aux départements aux conseils
départementaux ou là pour le 2ème
s'applique des principes
constitutionnels
même si nous avons intégré aussi dans le
redécoupage la représentation des
territoires
à travers les amendements qui ont été
d'abord voté à l'assemblée nationale
puisqu'une majorité du sénat n'a pas
voulu de ce texte
c'est à l'assemblée nationale nous avons
pris y compris un amendement du groupe
u10 pour intégrer les territoires mais
il ya des principes constitutionnels et
ni ministre ni un parlementaire ne peut
les remettre en cause et cette
représentation des territoires ceux des
bases démographiques bien sûr mais aussi
en tenant compte de ce qu'est la réalité
de l'autre pays et je suis convaincu que
le redécoupage cantonal tiendra compte
de ces éléments mais dans une démocratie
notamment suffrage direct pas totalement
inconcevable que ce soit un homme une
femme une voix qui s'impose par non de
le rappeler pour ce qui concerne le
sénat plus de deux tiers des délégués
des conseils municipaux représentent les
communes de moins de 10000 habitants
alors que celle-ci ne regroupe que la
moitié de la population ce que nous
changeons drastiquement cet élément non
la population totale des communes de
plus de 100000 habitants est deux fois
plus élevée que celle des communes de
moins de 500 habitants tandis que ces
dernières disposent de deux fois plus de
délégués est ce qu on bouleverse la non
dans les communes de plus de 100000
habitants le nombre des délégués empare
du nombre total de délégués a même
évolué dans un sens défavorable à ces
grandes communes est dépassé de 8 3% du
total des délégués en 1964 à 7 45% du
total délégué en 2010 donc ne nous fait
pas un procès sur la représentation des
territoires
encadrés par le conseil non non parce
que là mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de l'opposition ce n'est pas
vrai il ce n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas
vrai ce n'est pas vrai nous changeons ça
a été expliqué tout à l'heure si vous
permettez
si vous permettez ce qu'expliquait très
bien le rapporteur tout à l'heure et le
président la commission des lois
l'article a pour objectif de
rééquilibrer la représentativité entre
les différentes catégories de communes
de façon à tenir compte de la croissance
démographique dans les plus grandes
communes c'est donc par un rajout c'est
tout le débat que nous avons eu pour les
grandes communes sans remettre en cause
la représentativité des petites communes
à raison d'un délégué supplémentaire par
tranche de 800 habitants au dessus de 30
mille habitants le nombre d'habitants
par délégués dans les communes de plus
de 300000 habitants seraient de 760
alors qu'il serait toujours de 227 dans
les communes de moins de 500 habitants
avec les évolutions démographiques que
notre pays a connus ne pourrions pas de
manière légère faire en sorte que ces
grandes communes et quelques délégués
supplémentaires et nous avons été très
raisonnable pour les raisons qui ont été
expliquées tout à l'heure à la fois
parce qu'il ya la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
et parce que le gouvernement jean-pierre
sueur viens de le dire ne souhaitait pas
mettre en cause les équilibres du sénat
alors accepter la diversité du pays
telle qu'elle est y compris dans la
représentation du sénat tout en tenant
compte de ce qu'est la représentation du
sénat c'est à dire aussi des territoires
et des collectivités acceptez le ne nous
faites pas un faux procès parce que
honnêtement la vous touchez pas le but
je passe la parole à monsieur favier oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
on a effectivement pris acte du
rééquilibrage il faut dire très bonne
est ce vous avez dit monsieur le
ministre je crois très prudent
d'ailleurs proposé avec un délégué pour
une bille sens et vous savez connaissez
notre attachement nous à l'égalité des
citoyens et nous pensons qu
effectivement nous aurions pu c'est ce
que nous avions proposé y compris aller
plus loin
notant que la mesure qui est proposé ne
concerne effectivement que les communes
de plus de 30000 habitants ça veut dire
que ça ne le retire absolument rien en
nombre de délégués pour les communes
plus petites
je leur ai dit aussi à mes collègues de
l'opposition quand même en tout cas noté
une certaine contradiction que ceux qui
il ya encore quelques jours
votre enthousiasme les grandes
métropoles qui dont on sait
effectivement qu'elles vont très
certainement conduire à réduire très
fortement le rôle et la place des
communes rurales et aujourd'hui les
entrants de vouloir défendre à tout prix
les communes rurales je pense qu'il ya
là effectivement une contradiction et
donc pour notre part nous ne voterons
pas évidemment ces amendements de
suppression et même malgré effectivement
la modestie de l'avancé nous votre ont
effectivement cet article merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à monsieur savary
j'ai bien écouté les propos de monsieur
le rapporteur et monsieur le ministre
qui disent que c'est minime
c'est une modification en minimes doc
raison de plus pour pas d'affaires il ya
bien quand même véritablement une
arrière-pensée monsieur le ministre
quand même nous on sait ce que si on a
pratiqué notre majorité a pratiqué des
découpages donc on sait bien ce que
c'est un là dessus je pense que
véritablement faut être clair il ya
toujours à travers ce système là une
volonté de faire en sorte que les
élections puissent se dérouler le mieux
poursuit le mieux possible pour celui
qui découpe
alors à quelques minutes d'intervalle on
voit bien qu'il ya une volonté de
défense du monde rural mais quand il
s'agit de passer à l'acte on voit bien
que les décisions sont inverses et on
vient de dire quelques minutes
auparavant suite à l'intervention
brillante de monsieur richard qui valait
peut-être mieux recalculé un petit peu
pour un nombre de délégués etc
et puis dix minutes après et ben hop on
repasse quelque chose qui insidieusement
pourraient faire en sorte que sans bruit
nous modifions les équilibre entre le
rural et l'urbain
or moi je crois que ya un rapprochement
puisque ça fait un certain nombre
d'heures qu'on passe dans cet hémicycle
a travaillé sur les élections
municipales départementales sénatoriales
aujourd'hui on voit bien que
tranquillement il ya quand même une
arrière pensée
on peut pas s'empêcher de penser à la
découpe territoriale en ce qui concerne
les futurs conseillers départementaux où
il y aura un binôme un homme une femme
et lui des villes qui ne siégera
peut-être même pas dans un collège parce
qu'ils n'auront pas de collège qui
n'aura pas d'effets en de route
départementale puisque étant à
l'intérieur d'une agglomération bien
souvent il ya eu désaccord entre le
département et l'agglomération n'obtient
plus de routes départementales à
l'intérieur des agglomérations qui avec
un peu de chance quand même aura
l'occasion d'exercer les compétences
sociales à travers les circonscriptions
de la solidarité si son compte en est
pour
vu et puis de l'autre côté un binôme
toujours une femme de conseillers
départementaux du monde rural avec
canton voilà qu'un plus de 90 communes
110 communes dans un des cantons qui
futur canton éventuelle selon votre bon
vouloir en ce qui concerne le
département de la marne avec un à deux
collèges un certain nombre de centaines
de kilomètres de routes départementales
donc de mission bien différente
donc on est légitimement en voie de
penser qu' il faut être vigilant à cet
équilibre entre le monde rural et le
monde urbain
en plus il faut souligner que c'est une
élection au scrutin indirect puisque les
conseillers municipaux sont désignés par
les électeurs pour prendre des
responsabilités en ce monde et entre
autres ensuite désigner le corps
électoral du sénat
hélas en rajoutant un certain nombre de
personnes à ce collège là c'est encore
une élection indirecte fait par des gens
désignés indirectement donc on voit bien
que on s'éloigne complètement des
électeurs de base c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis particulièrement
hostiles à cet article qui ont fait à
billes surtout l'article suivant pour le
passage à la proportionnelle dans les
départements de 3 de trois sénateurs et
je pense que c'est mieux de présenter
une loi avec quelques articles une loi
avec un sur lactique
celui de passer à la proportionnelle et
département à trois sénateurs
merci la parole à monsieur mauvais
merci monsieur le président sur le
présent soumises mes chers collègues moi
je voterai les amendements de
suppression de cet article pour les
raisons j'allais dire qu'ils sont
exposés dans l'étude d'impact puisque ça
a été rappelé l'étude d'impact
spécifique cette disposition a pour
objet d'assurer une meilleure
représentation des zones urbaines et une
meilleure prise en compte du poids
démographique des communes mais je suis
en désaccord total avec ce double
objectif renforcer les zones urbaines
ça veut dire n'en déplaise à monsieur le
ministre qui s'est agacé sur le sujet ce
qui montre qu'il est peut-être pas très
à l'aise sur ce point que quand on veut
renforcer le monde urbain c'est
forcément c'est forcément au détriment
du monde rural jeunes inverse ce n'est
pas possible et j'ai beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup aimé l'expression utilisée par
notre collègue tout à l'heure qui a
parlé de deux textes ruralys id parce
que effectivement on est dans des textes
ruralys ide et n'en déplaise là encore
au ministre le texte qui a été adopté
sur le mode de scrutin binominal pour
les élections départementales va dans le
même sens donc c'est toujours dans le
même sens qu'on va réduire à chaque fois
texte a pretext dispositif après
dispositif le poids du monde rural
et quand on dit qu'il faut assurer une
meilleure prise en compte du poids
démographique des communes
fractionnistes que vous avez dit la
discussion générale et je m'en étais
d'ailleurs étonné qu'on renforçant le
poids de la démographie ont renforcé les
territoires mais c'est évidemment
exactement l'inversé
l'été quand on parle de territoire on ne
doit pas prendre en compte le poids
démographique de ces territoires
on ne voit on ne doit pas prendre en
compte le nombre d'habitants de ces
territoires
je sais c'est l'assemblée nationale qui
représente le peuple donc le poids de la
démographie le nombre d'habitants d'un
territoire est exprimée dans les
élections législatives et non pas dans
les élections sénatoriales
et quand vous avez dit il ya quelques
instants qu'il y avait je crois que vous
avez dit qu'il y avait deux tiers des
délégués qui représenteraient les
communes de moins de 10000 habitants
je rappelle qu'il ya deux tiers des
communes qui ont moins de 500 habitants
donc on voit très bien qu'aujourd'hui
déjà il y à une prise en compte du poids
relatif des collectivités alors
l'argument qui nous est
mis en avant pour tenter de nous
rassurer c'est que finalement ça ne
changerait pas grand chose ma foi 3000
délégués sur 150 milles ça ne serait pas
beaucoup peut-être mais j'observe quand
même et ça a été soulignée notamment par
michel mercier par yves détraigne qu'il
y ait un certain nombre de départements
où il y aura notamment dans le rhône et
je crois que c'était souligné aussi dans
le val-de-marne où il y aura des impacts
très fort sur le collège électoral de
ces départements et puis comme je
l'indiquais c'est toujours toujours dans
le même sens que l'on va des mauvais
coup porté au monde rural au monde rural
texte après texte et qu'on entendait
tout à l'heure monsieur gorce dont les
propos pouvaient paraître provocant il
était effectivement tout à fait
provoquant je me demandais si quelque
part il n'était pas en service commandé
pour exprimer pour exprimer tout ce
qu'un certain nombre de parlementaires
socialistes pensent tout bas
le sénat est une anomalie démocratique
c'est un illustre socialiste qu'il a dit
est donc on essaie petit à petit parce
que fort heureusement il ya la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
mais on essaie quand même petit à petit
de renier sur le rôle du sénat comme
représentants des territoires et des
collectivités locales
donc je voterai je voterai ces
amendements de suppression
je passe la parole à monsieur philippe
basse
merci monsieur le président et je me
garderai bien monsieur le ministre de
faire un procès d'intention au
gouvernement ce n'est pas du tout
l'objet des différentes interventions
des membres du groupe auquel
j'appartiens
je voudrais simplement vous dire que
certes nous ne diminuons pas le nombre
de représentants du monde rural
mais nous augmentons le nombre de
représentants du monde urbain ce qui
veut dire qu'en valeur relative
le monde rural sera moins représentées
qu'avant ceci n'est pas un procès
d'intention c'est une simple
constatation elle est objective
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que et là c'est une question de
principe et elle est grave
à partir du moment où nous désignons de
plus en plus de grands électeurs
qui ne sont pas des élus de l'ocs de
leurs collectivités territoriales eh
bien nous allons sur un chemin qui est
mauvais car il a pour effet de diminuer
la portée du principe constitutionnel
selon lequel le sénat représente les
collectivités territoriales de la
république
et si dans leur sagesse les constituants
depuis plusieurs constitution ont prévu
exactement la même chose ce n'est pas
simplement pour faire plaisir aux
communes
c'est avec l'idée que s'il ya une
deuxième chambre elle doit avoir son
originalité et cette originalité repose
sur le fait que ces élus sont
sélectionnés par des élus en raison de
l'expérience qu'ils ont eux mêmes des
affaires publiques et qui leur permet
d'avoir une vision originale de la
manière dont il faut remplir cette
fonction sénatoriales à partir du moment
où dans certains départements on me
citer par exemple le chiffre des
hauts-de-seine
on va passer de 30 à 35 % la part des
grands électeurs qui ne sont pas des
élus mais qui seront donc des militants
eh bien on dénature l'institution
sénatoriales et cette question de
principe et pour moi tout à fait
essentiel on ne peut pas la passer par
pertes et profits
et je dois dire qu'à partir du moment où
vous utilisez toujours des ratios qui
rapporte le nombre de délégués
sénatoriaux supplémentaires non élu à
l'ensemble des délégués sénatoriaux de
d'un même département
on est sur la mauvaise voie alors vous
pouvez bien sûr dire que oui c'est une
petite goutte d'eau dans ce département
non ça n'est pas une goutte d'eau car
c'est important dans la commune qui va
pouvoir passer par exemple à 50% de
délégués sénatoriaux nos élus du fait
que vous aurez augmenter cette part de
délégués sénatoriaux nom est lui aussi
dans une ville importante mais ça existe
dans certains cas mais c'est un
correctif démographique qui a déjà été
fait on arrive à multiplier les cas où
il ya plus de délégués d'un élu que deux
délégués élus et bien on va au delà de
ce que nous considérons comme étant
respectueux des dispositions de
l'article 24 de notre constitution
et ça ça me paraît également très
important il me paraît également très
important
de le souligner monsieur le ministre
donc il me semble que il faut
effectivement refusé cet article premier
c'est la raison pour laquelle avec mes
collègues que je ne le voterai pas merci
mon cher collègue je passe la parole à
françois rebsamen
j'ai pris deux trois notes parce que on
a déjà eu ce débat finalement à travers
la discussion générale l'autre jour
chers collègues tout ce qui est excessif
est insignifiant et certaines des
remarques n'ont pas lieu d'être
comment parler d'un texte ruralys id
mais il s'agit absolument pas
aujourd'hui de diminuer la
représentation du monde rural
il s'agit d'augmenter légèrement la
représentation du monde urbain c'est pas
la même chose mais non maintenant quand
vous avez mes chers collègues vous êtes
suffisamment au fait suffisamment au
fait rural à la connaissance du fait
rural pour savoir que quand vous avez
une commune de 10 habitants par exemple
elle à un représentant
elle a un représentant elle a donc un
grand électeur c'est une commune donc
prenons le plancher une commune avec
zéro habitants à un représentant
avec 10 représente 10 habitent à la un
représentant une commune qui a
aujourd'hui deux cent mille habitants
elle a à peine 200 grands électeurs à
peine deux cents c'est à dire que le
rapport qui existe aujourd'hui dans
l'égalité territoriale
il est tout simplement de 1 à 100 de 1 à
100 or s'agit pas de diminuer la
représentation du monde rural
il s'agit d'équilibrer un peu plus pour
le monde urbain médocaine mais dans quel
monde vivez vous mais dans quel monde
vivez vous je suis sûr d'ailleurs la
plupart d'entre vous habite en ville et
vous voulez absolument pas en s p 6
vous refusez vous refuser bien sûr la
reconnaissance du fait urbain pas tous
heureusement il y en a quelques-uns je
suis sûr qu'ils sont attachés au fait
urbain au nom de la défense d'un monde
rural que d'ailleurs vous ne défendez
pas avec ce comportement parce que je
les ai déjà dit il y as d'interaction
entre le monde rural et le monde urbain
c'est dans nos communes c'est dans nos
agglomérations que le travail se
trouvent bien souvent et que ce fait les
changes
c'est là où il ya les activités
culturelles c'est là où les gens du
monde rural sont souvent heureux de
venir et c'est le monde urbain qui est
heureux d'aller à la campagne et dans le
monde rural le week-end mais c'est ça
les change alors vous vous êtes bloqués
vous avez pour tous une fois pour toutes
vous avez l'image l'image d'un monde
figé l'image d'un monde figé
vous êtes des conservateurs ça c'est
votre droit le plus strict mais c'est
votre droit le plus strict mais mais
vous êtes en réalité dans un autre monde
vous êtes dans un autre monde on l'a vu
on l'a vu sur d'autres débats on l'a vu
sur d'autres débats vous ne voyez pas la
société qui bouge
vous ne voyez pas la société évolue et
ça a été la raison de nombre de vos
échecs électoraux mais vous ne voulez
pas en tenir compte
ouais ça va on attendra nombre de vos
échecs électoraux d'importance et vous
ne pouvez même pas en tirer leçon parce
que vous ne faites pas inventaire de
cela parce que vous ne faites pas un
inventaire de cela et donc c'est pour
vous appeler à prendre en compte la
réalité qui a aujourd'hui un léger
rééquilibrage du monde urbain à mon avis
insuffisant je le dis comme je le pense
à mon avis insuffisant mais bien
évidemment mais bien évidemment je
regarde le souci de sérénité qui anime
le président de la commission des lois
le rapporteur et surtout le texte du
gouvernement qui est dans un souci
d'équilibré parfait et je me range avec
le groupe socialiste totalement derrière
ce projet du gouvernement
merci
merci la parole à monsieur cornu oui moi
je dois reconnaître à monsieur le
ministre
une certaine constance et même un fil
directeur c'est vrai que le gouvernement
au lieu de s'occuper de résoudre de
réduire le chômage au lieu de deux
s'occuper de la compétitivé entreprises
et et d'améliorer le pouvoir d'achat de
nos concitoyens
c'est vrai que je vous trouve remarque à
monsieur le ministre
puisque vous arrivez en un an à vous
occuper et à bidouiller les élections
électorales tous les niveaux municipale
intercommunale cantonales et maintenant
sénatoriales est pire
et pire avec une mauvaise foi évidente
ou alors vous ne savez pas compter ce
que je pense que c'est pas je pense que
malheureusement c'est la mauvaise foi
qui prédomine parce que franchement
franchement c'est le monde rural que
vous méprisez c'est le monde rural que
vous voulez atteindre c'est bien ça la
réalité c'est bien ça parce que la
proportionnelle on le voit bien
c'est encore le montrera qui qui est
atteint c'est ça en fait que vous voulez
parce que vous voulez bidouiller les
élections pour rester au pouvoir
mais vous méprenez pas vous avez vu les
résultats dimanche en faisant en
accentuant tout cela eh bien les
français ne seront pas dupes
vous verrez qu'en changeant les
élections un an des élections
sénatoriales le mode d'élection
eh bien vous verrez que les français
nous condamnerons parce que ça ne se
fait pas il faut arrêter quand même nous
prendre pour les imbéciles
je passe la parole à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
sénateur vous me faites beaucoup de
donner des responsabilités majeures
concernant la politique économique la
compétitivité et et le chômage mais vais
je vais unies monsieur le sénateur ce
sont des sujets difficiles compliquées
vu la situation du pays que nous avons
trouvé et cela et cela devrait nous
amener en tout cas vous un tout petit
peu plus de molly sims eu philippe babin
je vois bien que vous aviez la foi du
charbonnier du converti élus ici au
sénat enfin vous avez été ministre vous
avez je suis au gouvernement ça je vous
le confirme vous vous n'y est plus les
électeurs sont passés par là mais en
tout état cause ça devrait nous amener
les uns et les autres à de la modestie
est en tout cas il ya des mots que vous
avez employé qui je ne doute pas un seul
instant dépasse votre pensée
le gouvernement présente un certain
nombre de textes électoraux
nous avions pris un engagement
concernant l'annulation l'abrogation du
conseiller territorial
cet engagement a été tenu vous le saviez
façon il n'était pas rentré en
application et puis nous présentons un
texte qui concerne le sénat et qui me
paraît être équilibré et qui revient
d'ailleurs pour ce qui concerne la
proportionnelle sur des choix qui
avaient déjà été mises en oeuvre
quand nous étions au pouvoir mais
franchement sur les mots concernant la
ruralité
je suis ministre de l'intérieur donc je
suis aussi en charge effectivement est
d'abord de la sécurité des français mais
qui a supprimé plus de 10000 postes de
policiers et de gendarmes dans ce pays
si ce n'est votre gouvernement et votre
majorité au cours de ces dernières
années qui a créé les conditions d'une
hémorragie sans précédent dans la
gendarmerie
c'est à dire la force qui a las en
charge la sécurité dans les territoires
ruraux
c'est vous qui a mis en cause
l'organisation des brigades de
gendarmerie dans les territoires ruraux
c'est vous
alors je n'accepte pas les leçons
concernant le monde rural car vous par
votre politique économique par votre
politique agricole et par votre
politique de sécurité
vous avez mis en cause le monde rural
nous n'avons aucune leçon à recevoir de
votre part dans ce domaine là merci
monsieur le ministre je passe la parole
à monsieur le sénateur alain richard il
est peut-être possible de garder les
conditions d'un dialogue courtois et
amicale je sens que l'âne ou l'autre
peuvent le souhaitait ici donc je
voudrais simplement poursuivre le
raisonnement
plusieurs collègues ont évoqué la
difficulté pour le monde rural résultant
du système qui a été adoptée pour les
élections départementales mais je me
permets de rappeler que nous avons les
uns les uns et les autres à notre tour
saisi le conseil constitutionnel de
toutes les lois électorales petites ou
grandes qui ont été adoptées au cours
des trente dernières années
et chacun notre tour nous avons parfois
pris le manche du râteau dans la figure
et une bonne partie des décisions
adoptées par le conseil constitutionnel
que nous avions sollicité ont abouti à
des solutions qui ne nous convenait pas
et je voudrais en particulier souligné
le fait que quand il s'agit d'élection
directe cas des élections
départementales le conseil ne peut pas
faire autrement que d'appliquer le
principe un homme une voix
il leur est énonce à toutes les lois
électorales depuis 30 ans est vrai
souligné en particulier que même dans le
cas des intercommunalités
en 1995 on sent sur une loi adoptée par
la majorité soutenant monsieur pasqua à
l'époque le conseil constitutionnel dit
que même pour les représentations
interco
nan on était obligé de respecter le
principe un homme une voix et c'est ce
qui vous a conduit comme nous dans la
loi que vous aviez présenté en 2009 à
prévoir que il y aurait une
représentation proportionnelle
démographique des représentations
communautaire donc nous sommes sur les
rails et je voudrais ajouter pour
détendre l'atmosphère que cette
opération du râteau vient encore de se
produire car comme je l'avais prévu
gentiment un peu ironiquement alors que
vous avez un grand concours
d'ingéniosité pendant le débat sur le
conseil départemental pour prévoir le
maximum d'ouverture entre le maximum une
minimum de population d'un canton on
s'était plus ou moins mis d'accord sur
un écart de moins 30 à +30 % avec en
plus des dérogations comme je l'avais
prévu le recours présenté par vous mes
chers collègues devant le conseil
constitutionnel a voulu faire usage au
maximum du principe d'égalité
démographique et il a obtenu
satisfaction
si bien que sur votre demande sur votre
saisine on a supprimé le conseil a
supprimé de la loi du 17 mai toute
possibilité de dérogation à l'égalité
démographique
donc il me semble que sur ce point là on
a tous un peu à prendre de l'expérience
et un peu de réserve à garder maintenant
en ce qui concerne l'élection indirecte
du sénat on peut avoir cette divergence
pour savoir si le léger rééquilibrage
qui se fait en faveur de l'as de la
représentation démographique des
communes urbaines est un dérapage
jeffrey observé en particulier mon
excellent collègue monsieur bas que dans
la décision de 2000 du conseil
constitutionnel celle sur la précédente
réforme sénatoriales le conseil a pris
la peine de préciser que le dispositif
en vigueur à l'époque la loi dont avec
les pondérations de 2000 était conforme
aux principes constitutionnels
or cette loi à ce moment-là comprenez et
ça ne défrise est personne une forte
correction démographique en faveur des
villes et y avait déjà des départements
dans lesquels les représentants les
commandites ont les délégués
supplémentaires représenté 20 25 30 % du
corps électoral
il n'est venu à l'esprit de personne de
le supprimer donc ce sont bien des
choses avec lesquelles nous vivons et
qui représente un équilibre correct un
équilibre réfléchi et délibérée entre la
représentation de la diversité des
collectivités et la représentation
tenant compte de du principe un homme
une voix qui n'est quand même pas un
attentat à la représentation
territoriale dernières observations il
n'est pas possible en droit de prétendre
que des élus représentent des
territoires il représente toujours des
êtres humains est d'ailleurs nos
collègues de la commission des lois ne
s'y sont pas trompés puisqu'ils étaient
arrivés de la créativité spontanée du
groupe ump un amendement qui prévoyait
dénoncé en principe que les sénateurs
représenter les territoires
on leur a fait observer calmement et
respectueusement que ceux ci risquait de
se heurter à une objection
constitutionnel parce qu'on ne peut pas
représenter les territoires vide on ne
représente que les humains qui les
occupent
et donc les collègues ont eu la sagesse
de retirer cet amendement
il me semble donc qu on peut se
rapprocher et s'écouter calmement
merci monsieur richard je passe la
parole à monsieur doligé
chers collègues juste quelques petites
remarques et j'espère je vais le faire
avec beaucoup d'attention pour pas
m'attirer les foudres de monsieur le
ministre donc pour qu'il puisse garder
son calme comme on le garde nous aussi
on essaye en tout cas sera sujet qui qui
est important mais effectivement quand
on nous dit comme le président et moi
même tout à l'heure que tout est
excessif est insignifiant
je pense qu'il a joué un peu dans cette
cour-là tout à l'heure dans sa
démonstration également il pourra
vérifier un peu son intervention donc à
chacun de défendre nos arguments j'ai
peur qu effectivement le râteau l'on
vient de parler monsieur richard vous
ayez beaucoup de chance de marcher
toujours dessus un jour compte tenu des
modifications successives qui arrive et
on s'aperçoit très bien que lorsque l'on
joue avec les règles électorales on a
parfois quelques surprises sur le
conseiller territorial puisque tout à
l'heure on nous a dit bon ça suffit nous
expliquer toujours un certain nombre de
choses mais le débat il faudrait qu'il
avance je vous rappellerai que le
conseiller territorial
regardez le temps qu'on a passé sur le
conseiller territorial alors qu'on avait
essayé de ne modifier qu'une chose au
niveau des différentes strates de
collectivités c'était le conseiller
territorial et ça a été le point de
focalisation alors effectivement là il
ya plus de points de focalisation ce que
ça parte tous azimuts
je me permet quand même de rappeler
alors bon ne parlons pas de la ruralité
c'est vrai que on n'a pas touché dans
toutes les règles électorales à tout ce
qui pourrait atteindre la ruralité mais
quand même quand on a changé le seuil de
3500 âmes il a quand même eu un petit
changement dans les élections au niveau
des communes et des communes rurales on
va bien voir ce que ça va apporter comme
changement dans l'est dans les mois à
venir
quand on a changé dans
l'intercommunalité le fléchage on a
quand même fait quelques changements et
on entend dire qu'à terme il est pas
impossible qu en matière d'urbanisme
cela soit transférée aux
intercommunalités et j'entends beaucoup
de communes rurales qui me disent si on
perd l'urbanisme on se demande ce que
l'on va devenir dans nos territoires
ruraux et quel sera notre rôle
et puis quand on en arrive au
département on va pas revenir sur
l'élection du binominal bon mais quand
on dit un homme une voix
c'est vrai on a essayé de le faire dans
la tranche +20 -20 dans un département
mais souvent quand vous prenez le
département voisin qu'est sur un même
territoire
vous pouvez avoir une voix qui
représente dix fois plus de voix que
dans le département voisin
il ya beaucoup moins de population et il
ya autant de cantons donc ça a été fait
département par département et sap a été
vu dans une autre dans une autre vision
et puis ensuite on en vient aux
élections sénatoriales alors il est vrai
je le reconnais monsieur le ministre que
vous n'avez pas touché à la ruralité
c'est vrai bon mais comme cela a été dit
par mes collègues il y en a quand même
plus dans le monde urbain donc par
comparaison les 3000 sur 150 milles ça
pèse quand même et on sait tous que dans
certains endroits ça plus à +1 toutes
ces petites touches à conserver le même
corps électoral au niveau des régionales
et les cantonales modifier un peu par ci
et par là ça du poids quand nous sommes
sur des élections avec des écarts qui
sont extrêmement faibles
et puis donc vous allez peut-être
peut-être toucher aux élections
législatives donc en un ample ça sera
quand même pas mal comme tableau de
chasse puisqu'on parle de la
proportionnelle et à qu'une élection que
vous avez oublié dans la chaîne c'est
les élections régionales
et on se demande pourquoi cherchez
l'erreur les élections régionales
alors moi je serais pour que parce que
en entendant tout à l'heure mon collègue
albéric de montgolfier je pensais que
dans le l'emploi du temps qu'on allait
avoir il allait y avoir quelque chose
sur les élections régionales pour que je
n'ai pas entendu mais peut-être qu'on
pourrait mettre du binominal dans les
élections régionales
je trouve que ça serait un beau débat un
beau débat qu'on pourrait avoir dans
notre assemblée
qui je pense serait simple maintenant
qu'on a l'expérience puis au moins le
département se serait pas unique au
monde
on aurait au moins les régions également
alors juste pour revenir sur un chiffre
puisque tout à l'heure notre collègue
rebsamen deux chiffres rebsamen nous a
dit que il y avait un écart de 1 à 100
moi je vais vous dire que dans le
nouveau conseiller territorial le
nouveau conseiller
je suis plus grands ils s'appellent
départementale il y aura un écart
parfois de 1 200 voire de 1 à 300 dans
le travail corps à faire un conseiller
départemental
selon qu'il est dans une grande villa
d'ici se partagent une ville alors que
dans le monde rural à seul il peut avoir
trente villes donc vous allez voir la
différence de travail dernier chiffre
que je vais vous donner ça n'a l'air de
rien mais le fait de passer de modifier
donc la répartition et bien maintenant
au lieu d'être dans des communes de
80000 qui auront plus d'électeurs
désignent et qui sont hors du corps
communal de la commune et qui sont des
personnes extérieures
et bien maintenant on va tomber dans des
communes de 70000 donc on descend de
strates dans les communes de 70000
maintenant vous aurez plus d'électeurs
qui sont hors de la municipalité que des
lecteurs du conseil municipal que des
lecteurs qui sont l'intérieur de vous
voyez que toutes les modifications à
sens merci mon cher collègue
oui monsieur le président en guinée vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur me lis mes chers
collègues
simplement je je vais revenir sur
l'intervention de monsieur ministre et
de monsieur le ministre richard
également je crois que ce n'est pas
forcément l'endroit pour faire l'exégèse
des décisions du conseil constitutionnel
une fois cet intéressant et ça nous
rajeunit un petit peu alors simplement
je voudrais rappeler que le conseil
constitutionnel ne s'est pas prononcé
sur l'écart du plus ou moins 30% et je
pense qu'il ne s'est pas attaché à dire
que l'on devait respecter strictement le
principe une voie d'une voix pour une
personne je crois que c'est intéressant
parce que en fait il a simplement dit on
avait utilisé peut-être des formules un
peu alambiqué et qui faisait qu'on
pouvait aller beaucoup plus loin que ne
le permettait
son approche et je crois que c'est
intéressant parce que je trouve qu'il
est un peu malséant de ce s'appuyer sur
la décision du conseil constitutionnel
pour expliquer ce texte merci je mets
aux voix ces quatre amendements je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par les groupes ump socialistes sur ces
amendements
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable que l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques instants
d'autre part
vous
v
oui
voilà
beaucoup
on
jours
il
côté
vous
et le souletin et nos jeunes mais
secrétaire a cantonné au déroulement du
scrutin
oui
je
ah oui
puis
comment
il
je
résultat du scrutin numéro 2 159 sur les
armes en numéro 2 23 32 et 39 tendant à
la suppression de l'article 1er nombre
de votants 347 nombre de suffrages
exprimés 347 pour l'adoption 171 contre
le sénat n'a pas adopté ces amendements
à